you don't say squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur la bêta de dette qui est un
jeu assez marrant en fait je joue soit
le des requins soit des plongeurs et le
but c'est de rester en vie dans tout ce
bordel on n'a encore jamais joué au jeu
ça point fois qu'on joue c'est parti
vous êtes prêt ou pas la banique est
alors si vous êtes pris comme ça mais
calloway tube on voit où es-tu mon amour
de maintenant attendez chiant quoi je
suis d'ailleurs oui il faut que tu
modifies des touches je te protège le
temps que tu modifies t touch mais alors
ne bougeait pas les gars vous avez peur
de bouger est meilleur on va se faire
attaquer dans pas longtemps aux médias
je sais pas peut être protégé n'atteint
selon lui la glace et la gasba c'est
bien sûr partie théorique 1 mais kader
toi moi j'ai un gros mécano de but c'est
de protéger ce space de robots qui
essaie d'ouvrir des comptes bancaires a
de l'argent et le but de tartas hugo c
nous défoncer des requins voilà
l'explication
voilà c'était l'explication y en a un
bon gars tu leur as n est qu à bucarest
aux alentours de nous là l'arrière ce
que j'ai posée qu'à la fin c'est bien là
il a fait péter la bombe que j'ai poussé
chatte à tulle et aussi à deux bonnes
questions avec mickey mois mais ils sont
passibles font rien ils tirent pas et
bouge pas et enfin ils sont ils ont bâti
à vos enfants à l'upac outils leur
cerveau alors là là là j'ai acheté un
truc de ouf les gars là je vous le dis
regarde ce que j'ai dans la main à mes
parts aucun là mais c'est pas ça c'est
bon on voulait jeter capturer grosse
merde alors
mais on n'a pas le temps de se parler
avec mickey ne voit jamais quoi quand je
lui parle il est dans la gueule d'un
requin qui ont une page sur la gueule
d'un week-end quand on fait tout à fait
aller c'était bon ben ouais mickaël var
cac est passé qu'approchait rebuy
qu'après au sénat comme ça trois
théories près des comores au jeu le
moral est tué ok partager le butin
ok je te suis sans voix vas-y on devrait
assister ou mika du parti là bas tu as
pas de chance parce que je te vois ta ta
ta ta ta ta bas j'ai tué michael est un
box n'est pas tout j'ai fait
je me tue pas tu me décapite quoi avec
ton espèce de bâton de poids angels à
mesa cbi casse a eu lieu vers une caisse
comme ça et burqa dans ta face à salloum
c'était une blague
[ __ ] je lui ai rien tu voir une entrée
avec style salle hugot 6 avril à comment
ça va comment ça va j'ai dit mais merde
y'a mon coeur qui passe à dire qu'un
requin pas loin d'un voyage gardien
kadhafi yahia a bondi qui est un humain
qui est sorti deux mois à quoi allait me
lüscher la guenon son nom âge à
l'évangile est parachuté manger merci
lucas de rien aux artifices juste ici
aux plats aux noms mais j'étais je vais
te le redis je vois je vois mika attends
je me fais micka mickaël fait de la
plongée dans la vraie vie
d'habitude quand il a pu s'acheter la
meilleure arme quoi
lots en plus ils campent en eau dans
cette salle où là je me le fais donc à
cheval faire jouer au legs
on l'a eue ce [ __ ] moi je fais
tellement peur que j'arrive par le
sultan atteint ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
je t'ai eue c'était toi parce que je
suis beau gars est un jeu bayonne
meilleurs élèves ainsi qu'aux jo oui
bien joué mon gars tu n'étais pas bon
pour un joueur c'est tout à toi ce que
tu prends pour un one shot c'est le art
pointe est explosive
oui as tu es vraiment une petite [ __ ]
il ya bien marqué en énorme fait imposer
un requin en moins de 0,5 seconde bombe
à écoute tard teinter le seul requin
contre nous avec deux beaux jeans
offensif s'est pas mal passé lui c'est
impossible
j'ai pas vu le mari cardiaque vient aux
chats sont chasse le rouquin par la
chasse et l'année la barre et j'arrive
j'arrive jared ross stores oui je les ai
eus avec mon couteau comme ça dans les
nappes d'eau les narines et regarde il
est content ça se voit m castany lullaby
fauchier mais c'est la vengeance jamais
vu quelqu'un aussi peu respectueux tiens
ça suffit c'est quoi la petite soit elle
est là il est avocat
merci d'ailleurs parfois non ça revient
là j'ai pas envie d'être tranquille il
appelait gens qui n'aiment pas vu à
temps il ya un truc qui tombe et c'est
toi tu attaques parce qu'en fait j'ai
tapé contre america c'est l'apport
refait mois et s'est agacé à temps mais
bon je le casque lui notamment à évaluer
il ya des trésors ici c'est pour moi
voilà donc pour moi aussi tu es bon mois
barry poste avait trésor
la raison je veux ma part j'aime le
faire boss aux visiteurs
enfin en haut olala c'est bon les gars
j'ai le harpon boom au bal du temps mais
ça alors seront quittes correct à la
main y en a il est mort et un deuxième
gros élément aussi parce que moi je m'en
vais les gars moi je revais à la surface
c'est parti on y va attends j'ai fait un
bon tour qu'un voilà attend que tu as
une petite danse regarde 0 [ __ ] tu toi
tu te fais comme un roc un effet de
reculer encore encore
toujours plus vite encore aux ménages
projet le bot est pas le le bon mec qui
est là juste là
moi j'ai des petits pois est juste là
non mais durera pas pareil je te laisse
cela aux data rate et ut cogner dis donc
tu es sûr que tu veux venir par là non
or on voit alors lorsque sinon c'est le
tata pas
oh la la la la la barack hussein obama
papa papa j'ai eus sous l'euro s'est en
outre honda qui attrapent d'autres aux
gens sous l'eau ses hommes
zhang qui protège les habitués le surmoi
tu vas avoir qui toi web le volet papa
et qui les meilleurs requins de paris si
nous fait du bruit dans la cage
oui est-ce que vous êtes prêts les
enfants
non se fait défoncer me tiens all bat à
aller sata calme et 1
il arrive par l'est y pala jeu d'esquivé
labeaume a en fait ils ont gâché ma joie
que non j'ai choisi les requins ont
vaincu oui je ramasse tout au trésor
n'ont arrête légal c'est mon trésor je
bouge plus c'était pas que tu fais quoi
penser non allez tomb raider de
l'aquatic a qu'un cache pas oui je suis
caché mon amour je suis caché mon amour
du cathétérisme mois de grosses merdes
passé moi que c'était les bouffer la
torpeur voire non j'essaie de choper il
y avait ceux ci n'ont pas bougé on est
cachée on s'en va et c'est que je
n'étais génie des génies des booms up et
là je me tire dessus par mao
ce que je sais pour le couverture de
rien c'était un filet il ya des trésors
là dans les étagères en fret avait déjà
vu merci à gauche trop tard mais il ya
trop de cadavres l'aria toile en regard
d'autres aucun ne sont pas loin mon gars
mais on dirait qu'on fait du sport
tellement déconcentré fils et volées à
travers la salle elle allait faut tenir
mais qu'on a plus qu'un ticket oui car
on n'a droit qu'à une mort des trois
clubs pas [ __ ] [ __ ] on a perdu
regardez moi même me balader à l'aimer
cas on se concentre ont fait appel à
atos kid de requins aux salades c'est
pas mal ça je sais que tu es la tarte 1
si si si c'est toi en tenant non regarde
pas ses mots alors les gars vous êtes
membre on a juste eu et c'est bien
highfive de requins au nom au nom elle
paye virtuel mis ko non
vas-y non mais il n'a pas eu le temps de
te suis comme ça c'est brad il te prends
moi non
wee aa à a les notes afférentes sur
notre banc d'essai comme le gign quoi
monsieur pépy gestion et voit les gens
c'est déjà fin de cette vidéo sur des
faits c'est quoi le nom déjà [ __ ]
l'inspecteur dave bêta pardon voilà
c'est comme cette dame et enfin ça n'a
rien à voir en fait ça si vous appuyez
circa n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude mais ça vous regarde et ont
surtout retenu dans une nouvelle vidéo
chat monde pis
m